The general good experience,
that's another thing you keep saying,
aim low enough.
Have a low enough bar.
Why do you.
Why do you mean that?
Well,
let's say you've got a kid and you want
the kid to improve.
You don't set them a bar that's so high
that it's impossible for them to attain
it.
You take a look at the kid and you
think,
okay,
this kid's got this range of skill.
Here's a challenge we can throw at him
or her that exceeds their current level
of skill,
but gives them a reasonable probability
of success,
and so like I'm saying it tongue and
cheek to some degree,
you know it's like,
but if you're.
But I'm doing it as an aid to humility.
It's like,
well,
I don't know how to start improving my
life.
Someone might say that,
and I would say,
well,
you're not aiming low enough.
There's something you could do that you
are regarding as trivial that,
that you could do that you would do that
would result in an actual improvement,
but it's not a big enough improvement
for you.
So you won't lower yourself enough to
take the opportunity.
Incremental steps.
Yes.
And so this is also what is achieved
through exercise.
It's one of the most important.
Yeah.
Well what do you do when you go and lift
weights?
You don't go in,
like if you have a bench press before
you don't put 400 pounds on the damn bar
and dropped and dropped the bar through
your skull.
You know,
you think,
look,
when I started working out,
when I was a kid,
I was,
I was weighed about 130 pounds and I was
six foot one was a thin kid and I smoked
a lot.
I wasn't in good shape.
I wasn't in good physical shape and I
went to the gym and it was bloody
embarrassing,
you know,
when people would come over and help me
with the goddamn weights,
here's how you're supposed to use this.
You know,
it was humiliating and maybe I was
pressing 65 pounds or something at that
point,
you know,
but what am I going to do?
I'm going to lift up 150 pounds and
injure myself right off the bat.
No,
I had to go in there and strip down and
put my skinny God damn self in front of
the mirror and think son of a bitch.
There's all these monsters in the gym
would be lifting weights for 10 years
and I'm struggling to get 50 pounds off
the bar.
Tough luck for me,
but I could lift 50 pounds and it wasn't
very long until I could lift 75 and
well,
you know,
how it goes,
but.
And I never injured myself when I was
weight lifting and the reason for that
was I never pushed myself past where I
knew I could go and I pushed myself a
lot.
You know,
I gained 35 pounds of muscle in about
three years in university.
I kind of had to quit because I was
eating so God damn much.
I couldn't stand it seeming like six
meals a day.
It was just taken up too much time,
but there's a humility in determining
what it is that the wretched creature
that you are can actually manage.
Aim Low,
and I don't mean don't aim and I don't
mean don't aim up,
but you have to accept the fact that you
can set yourself a goal that you can
attain and there's not going to be much
glory in it to begin with because if
you're not in very good shape,
the goal that you could they could
attain tomorrow isn't very glorious,
but it it's a hell of a lot better than
nothing and it beats the hell out of
bitterness and it's way better than
blaming someone else.
It's way less dangerous and you could do
it and what's cool about it,
there's a statement in the New
Testament,
it's called the matthew principle,
and economists use it to describe how
the economy in the world works to those
who have everything more will be given
from those who have nothing.
Everything will be taken.
It's like what's very pessimistic in
some sense because it means that as you
start to fail,
you fail more and more rapidly,
but it also means that as you start to
succeed,
you succeed more and more rapidly,
and so you take an incremental step and
well,
now you can lift 55 pounds instead of 52
point five pounds.
You think,
well,
what the hell is that?
It's like it's one step on a very long
journey and so it's,
and it starts to compound on you.
So a small step today means puts you in
a position to take a slightly bigger
step the next day,
and then that puts you in a position to
take a slightly bigger step the next
day.
And you do that for two or three years.
Man,
you're starting to stride everyone who's
fighting in these older leagues or if
they,
if golden boy,
if that's your thing,
to do like these,
this master league,
everyone fighting that lead better.
Pray to the MMA.
God's Vituro Balfour does not enter that
fucking thing.
Juice to the gills.
Oh,
have you seen lately?
Yes.
You better looks amazing.
Fantastic.
So happy we will.
We'll kick the fuck out of all those old
dudes at the same time.
He really.
Well Dude,
I was looking at his instagram the other
day.
I was like,
oh my God.
Yeah,
there's something happens to veto or
when he fills up with super unleaded
dude,
it's like butter and Jelly.
He's a different roads bro.
Like some people don't.
Don't,
don't do well with Roy to get all red
and shit.
He looks great.
His skin's vibrant,
his tits are popping.
All Tans teeth get wider.
He's doing straight testosterone.
He's not mean when he was on.
See,
think about this,
right?
We know for sure.
We all know absolutely 100 percent of
the people have cheated and taking
steroids and got away with it.
We know that.
I know.
You know that.
Especially in fighting,
especially when the weigh ins were the
only day you had a pee and there was no
randoms.
That didn't just come by.
We know for a fact,
but when you watch someone who's just
doing testosterone and what else is
doing with human growth hormone and
fucking gigantic now.
I love that.
I love it too,
but what you get there,
it's a different thing like for
Vittorio,
like something happens with him,
like when you,
when they allowed him to take it,
like during the rockhold fight and
bisping fight dude,
his body,
he ate it up,
but that's kind of a different thing.
First of all,
under control.
I was always a happy kid but not really
because I was always confused about the
death of my father so I'd always have
happiness,
but I always had the Catholic faith.
I was raised Catholic.
I always believed he wasn't having that.
He was in that box from my mom did the
things,
so these the pain a little bit.
Then my mother's death was just fuck it,
and that broke the central nervous
system belief system
that broke your belief in the world.
How can there be a god that takes a
mugger away from a child
when you're 16 and you wrap that around?
Your head does not a good result.
It's not going to be a good result.
So how I lashed out was by robin you.
That was the only weapon I had was to
rob you.
Joe Rogan fucked me.
This studio would get robbed and living
on fucking fire and Joe knew was and
what the fuck was he going to do?
I'm with Columbine.
The fuck you going to do it?
Call the cops.
It's Karma.
Going to answer the phone next time.
Don't fuck with me.
You'll know next time.
Not The fuck I tell you to give me that
gram of coke and I'll pay you on Friday.
You'll fucking give it to me,
right?
Because that's what it was.
It was simple shit like that.
Like,
Joe,
give me 100 bucks.
I broke $100 bucks.
Okay,
now rob,
your fucking house should have gave me
the hundred bucks.
You know,
I was lashing out of the fucking world.
Number two.
The other issue I had is I lost a child.
I loved the job.
I was not ready for that child at all.
I love that little girl with all my
heart,
but I was not ready for her at all.
My intentions are good,
but the result was not going to be well.
I was not ready and because I lost that
child and I'm a no contact with that
child,
it makes me a better father than I am
today.
This is never going to happen to me
again.
You understand me?
I see.
I see the,
we see daughters of comics,
we've seen daughters of comics,
comics and if fucking lost,
you know,
I don't want my daughter to be fucking
lost.
And that stupidity in the net world,
you know,
you have to be that.
We have to be there
dealing cocaine.
Oh good.
Like to that vest story man.
So here's what happened.
So I,
you know,
I would get using cocaine at thousand,
put on these different vests.
How many did you buy it again?
I don't know.
I spent too much on them,
but I would probably say
the price.
Yes.
One I had was probably about 200.
$10.
90.
Damn.
Yeah.
And so I would get fucked up and put
these vests on and put on sunglasses and
not let them know like Buffalo Bill
Shit.
But at least party and by myself,
you know.
And one time I was making a smoothie,
you know,
because I,
I have,
I got like a new unknown what kind of or
it is,
but it's pretty nice and I was making
like a nice smooth,
you know,
I'm fucking coked up on partying and you
know,
living high on the hog to vests on
maybe.
Right.
And I thought,
I thought I heard something outside.
Right.
Which is kind of weird to even think of
when you have a blender going,
right?
So I'll leave out of my apartment to go
in the hallway,
lock myself out with the blender going
in the morning,
coked up out of my brain.
Now I have to go to my landlord dude who
lives right down the hall and tell him
like,
hey man,
I got logged out Glenda's on.
Oh my God,
he must have hated you.
Owe the blender shorts out and smoke
happens.
The fire alarm starts going off in the
building,
right as I'm at his door knocking right
now.
He's pissed and he's like,
what's going on?
And I didn't know what to say.
I told him that I was throwing a late
Christmas party.
It was fucking into January.
I will with you at the time.
Huh?
Oh,
this is two and a half years ago.
So was 30,
35.
So he comes back to my apartment,
right?
He's,
he unlocks the door.
There's nobody in there.
Oh my God.
I'm like,
man,
but that's it.
It was fun.
Oh my God.
No,
that was fun.
How long had you lived there for?
I still live there.
Yeah,
we've passionate,
you know,
like I've caught him doing some things.
I think we're all even.
How long have you been sober?
For?
Two year.
In two weeks it'll be two years.
What was the big thing where you like,
oh,
I gotta get my shit together.
You Die.
What was going on?
Opion Jim,
when Opie and Jim Norton had a radio
show at serious and it was actually on
a,
it's on [inaudible] that show that he
had.
This is not happening.
And I ended up,
uh,
doing coke all night driving a taxi.
I was in a taxi.
The driver is due to Luigi.
Um,
got me an escort.
I didn't want to escort,
we're doing cocaine and like Harlem or
something north,
the cab driver doing coke and I just
had,
I was taking a cab from a party to my
hotel and so we ended up off on this
other excursion.
Next thing you know,
I'm driving the taxi.
He's in the back with the hooker.
It's 5:30 in the morning and I got to be
on the radio station at 6:30 or
something.
So I get to the radio and I can't even
talk.
And uh,
and darryl strawberry's the other guest,
right?
Who's the baseball player who also had
drug problem,
but he's like 13 years sober.
And so it was this weird moment where
like,
I thought I was kind of cool,
but then here's a man who like,
I'd always in my head maybe somewhere
thought,
oh,
that guy's like a cokehead within here.
He is eloquent,
put together,
successful in here I am,
I can't even talk.
And I'm with two men that I admire.
Um,
you know,
opie and Jim Norton,
just to be honored to be on the show,
you know.
And so I was like,
this is,
I'm,
I'm not making choices.
Like there's some,
there's some unevenness here,
you know.
And so what did you do after the 2012
step program?
12 step program.
Yeah.
And then so yeah.
So I've been in that.
Then since then it has helped me out,
you know.